Within my department,
the elected officials of the city of Rennes,
capital of,
have been influenced
by 1 antispeciesist group.
Today,
they want to ban us from fishing
on the properties of their city.
They even went as far as
create 1 charter
in which
they publicly undertake to communicate
and inform about the risks
and nuisance
and the consequences of fishing.
We are therefore experiencing 1 unprecedented situation
where 1 piece of aatola from the ecology
want to prohibit the leisure of
twenty-one thousand Brazilian officers.
Worse still,
this green dictatorship is attacking today
without any fear of the fallout
after 3,000,000 pieces of fresh water and sea water.
How can we leave
do this kind of thing again ?
The will of antispecific elected officials is us!
It is to dictate the
conditions under which to practice
our fishery to oppose each other